johnson est donc arrivé en ukraine le
premier ministre britannique dit vouloir
protéger la souveraineté du pays face à
ceux qui veulent la détruire allusion
bien sûr aux russes qui auraient massés
des milliers de soldats à la frontière
bruno daroux bonjour bonjour j'ai les
choristes johnson s'engage donc
pleinement oui bon et johnson s'engage
pleinement dans cette crise avec
l'ukraine et il s'engage librement
puisque la grande bretagne ne fait plus
partie de l'union européenne donc il
n'est plus obligé de tenir compte des
avis des uns et des autres et du coup et
moi on retrouve la politique étrangère
un peu traditionnelle de la grande
bretagne en cas de crise c'est à dire un
alignement sur les positions américaines
des positions évidemment assez dur sur
le fait qu' il ya une menace imminente
de la part de l'armée russe à la
frontière avec l'ukraine
boris johnson là dessus est d'accord
avec washington il a envoyé des armes en
ukraine aujourd'hui donc il fait le
déplacement à kiev et en fait on se
retrouve un peu avec si vous voulez un
qu'anglo saxons grande bretagne etats
unis qui est sur une ligne assez dur un
camp continental paris berlin un peu
plus dans la dans la médiation et qui
lui se concentre surtout sur des progrès
concernant ce qui se passe à l'est de
l'ukraine dans le dans le don de basse
et puis il ya aussi ces pays d'europe de
l'est qui eux aussi sont très pros
américains on pense notamment évidemment
à la pologne et du coup semble se
dessiner une une sorte dax si vous
voulez entre la grande-bretagne
l'ukraine la pologne qui seraient ces
trois pays sur sur une ligne très ferme
vis-à-vis de la russie c'est sans doute
dans ce sens comment allaient les
déclarations de boris johnson à kiev
aujourd'hui et puis la prochaine étape
en tout cas du jour c'est ce coup de fil
entre anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov
avec le risque d'un nouveau dialogue de
sourds oui un nouveau dialogue de sourds
avec les russes qu'ils insistent
toujours un sur le fait qu'ils veulent
des précisions sur les garanties de
sécurité qui la réclament donc les
garanties de sécurité c'est le fait que
l'otan arrête de s'étendre
vers l'est et notamment en ukraine mêmes
reviennent aux positions que l'alliance
atlantique occupé en 1997 c'est à dire
avant qu'ils les élargissements aux pays
baltes à la pologne puis ensuite à la
hongrie et à la roumanie bon pour le
moment il est très peu probable que les
américains donnent des gages aux russes
les américains qui en revanche 10 on
peut discuter d'autres sujets concernant
la la sécurité du continent européen
notamment concernant les armes à moyenne
portée mais visiblement sans trop
convaincre moscou donc on verra bien on
sait simplement que hier au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu les ambassadeurs
russes et américains ont échangé des
mots doux 1 les russes accusant les
américains d'hystériser la période
actuelle par exemple il y à aussi à
noter aujourd'hui le déplacement du
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban à
moscou et il va y avoir une conférence
de presse commune entre
le dirigeant hongrois qui fait donc
partie de l'union européenne et fait
partie de l'otan mais qu'il ya une
proximité assez grande avec vladimir
poutine
ce sera en tout cas la première fois que
la lumière quand il prendra la parole
publiquement depuis le début de cette
crise publiquement en tout cas à
l'international